this episode brought to you by the black
tux premium rental suits and tuxedos
delivered ah here we go original classic
you know what did Tim Burton and Johnny
Depp become the people you call to tone
down the imagination critic let's we
need your help right away yeah tell me
all about it so there's great trouble
brewing in twat oh don't make me go
curiouser on your ass oh come on Alice I
know I'm doing a Disney live-action
remake month but they didn't even do an
animated through the looking-glass movie
yes but the animated Alice in Wonderland
so looks more like through the
looking-glass than the live-action
through the looking-glass survey trick
besides a lot has changed Tim Burton's
gone everything's more bright and
colorful even Johnny Depp's better
really all that happened it's only two
out of those three things yes all right
how do I get there doing eat something
or go through a magical door no we use
this technologically advanced I though
Evans I magical
well what do you think I think this
might actually work
[Music]
Wow I just can't get over how beautiful
everything looks I mean it's bright its
colorful surreal I mean dare I say if
there's a sense of wonder here good I
didn't want to have to cut off your
balls and feed them to my wildebeest it
sounds like you did I did but I won't
Ranas progress so remind me again what
the urgent matter is carrot juice is sad
and his entire family died in a fire
recently no long ago and we have to
stake our entire world upon making him
happy again okay look it sucks that he
said really sucks but it happens people
poke no we have to go back in time to
cause his family's death huh
as well as causing every horrible thing
that's ever happened in our world what
while trying to learn a lesson about not
being able to change the past but being
rewarded for changing the past repeat of
previous what it's mad isn't that the
way it's supposed to be yeah but there's
a difference between mad and dumb mad is
being concerned that a pocket watch is
two days slow or everybody's cheating to
win a race that everybody wins dumb is
trying to take those simple charming
ideas and turn into a big action
end-of-the-world thriller but I'm sure
you're sad if anything it pisses me off
that all our problems are sent around a
dumb bumping jackass buddy asshole it's
what you are well you're obviously no
help
come on carrot juice let's go back in
time and almost cause the end of the
world to perk you up
[Music]
yeah that's pretty much what happens
the sequel to the unfortunate
live-action hit Alice in Wonderland
happily didn't win over audiences or
critics on the one hand it's very easy
to see why it's continuing its lame
attempt and making Wonderland Oh under
land however did I confuse those two
into a rebellious act impact resistance
movie like its predecessor it has
virtually nothing to do with the Lewis
Carroll books but to its credit it does
actually have seeds of what Alice in
Wonderland was okay their seeds growing
under a brick house of dumb but they're
still seeds is it a shame then that this
one made less money despite it having
more elements from the books than the
original or is this series just getting
inevitably what it deserves let's take a
closer look this is Alice Through the
Looking Glass when I said there's
elements of the original I didn't mean
right away yeah Alice is the captain of
her own ship now and she's about as
commanding as Keira Knightley leading
pirates between the two of them I don't
think they could lead a school of fish
oh give credit to Alice played again by
Mia Wasikowska there is at least a
little investment in her performance
well granted after the last film and
aggressive blink would be welcomed at
this point
well toned down there Daniel day-lewis
but she doesn't have much to work off of
as once again she plays the ahead of her
time outsider who must prove she's tough
and independent before proving she's
interesting or has a personality
[Music]
cliched pompous uppity cocks have more
personality if you really think about it
no other company is in the business of
hiring female clocks let alone ships
captains my teeth can't get any bigger
but my monocle certainly can there will
be no further expeditions you will start
in files but in time my transition of
Billy Zane rogering affair it is almost
complete but my transition into the NBC
Peacock is almost complete let's just
agree we're sillier than anything we're
going to see in wonder man Underland
yes stupid movies your father said those
shares aside for me he gave them to your
mother who sold them to me a year ago
while you were gone along with the bond
on the house house bond stock shares
company ownership alice in wonderland'
everybody at this point the original
book she just got done talking with
flowers and met the Queen on a giant
chess board hell with that shit here
she's wondering whether or not she wants
to sign over her father's ship to save
her mother's house but it's in a garden
that's kind of the same thing
c-captain is no job for a lady you can't
just make things however you want them
to be clearly you've never met the
writers of these movies we do eventually
get to Underland as the caterpillar now
a butterfly leads her to the
looking-glass where she crosses over oh
no the guests are trying to get in
through the locked door hurry Alice
before they get in and ask what's going
on why is this urgent believe it or not
we actually do partake in some
Wonderland ish material knocking over
humpty dumpty bickering with chess
pieces doors leading to the sky so this
is what Alice in Wonderland could have
fed up bullshit what ho Hatter's the
matter he's grown darker he knows
himself laughter a new scheme of ours
can raise any sort of smile yep the Mad
Hatter is feeling sad because he came
across a blue hat that reminded him of
his family killed by the Queen of Hearts
not sure why Alice was brought in to
deal with this
maybe her slights
sense of acting direction can set off
taps complete lack of acting direction
my family moved to yeah it Depp's had
her acting in the first one was the
equivalent of his fantastic beast
performance then this one is definitely
his Mordecai performance it's like it's
Willy Wonka was too drunk to find a job
so he became the local Ronald McDonald
he looks beyond lost yeah yeah as a
whole in the world like a great black
pit and it's from this movie that's full
of shit because I know you're all
invested why don't you remind us of the
plot again Alice nine times cos travel
back in time to Horan vendor's day save
that as family from being killed and
thereby save the hat and then get McFly
to kiss at the prom so my picture will
come back and if your past self sees
your future self that really doesn't
sound worth the risk I mean I like the
Mad Hatter
yay I don't even like him but even if I
did it's not worth risking the entire
frigging world you know cuz it's the
entire friggin world of one of these
he's depressed sucks
grab him some prozac get him laid and
showing some Fresh Prince of bel-air -
this episode end of the world does not
need to factor into this she goes to the
center of time as she is the only one
who can do it because she's not from
around there oh those restrictive rules
that limit the imagination of Wonderland
under lamp she also discovers that time
is a he played by such a baron-cohen
who is that how did you get in
really it was a literal hop and a skip I
don't see where the impossible comes in
despite not being in the books this
character does surprisingly bring a
similar charming goofiness that would
probably be found in them it's actually
refreshing to hear ideas and wordplay
centered around time being explored
everyone nods with everything eventually
these miniscule artisans of my second
thank you for your use if Alice came
across time in the books I feel like
this is probably how it would go but
again it doesn't last long for guess who
shows up again no really they want you
to guess before they reveal her a
performer who used to be subtle but gave
it up for screaming and crazy hair the
other one there you go can we get that
fast forward thing back from earlier
these are the parts that really need it
it looks like time has fallen in love
with the abusive Queen of Hearts played
again by Helena bottoming out Carter as
it looks like she still has it in her
contract to have the camera two inches
away from her at all times
[Music]
okay you look like penny wise about to
French me please stop confusing the
camera for your toothbrush Ellis decides
to take control of the chronosphere to
go back in time to save Heather's family
but not before battling times minions
[Music]
I have to stop this from turning into a
lame is reunion I can't hear Russell
Crowe sing again she must have the
chronosphere all our hopes fly with you
[Music]
just a heads up the time traveling is
going great but the world may
accidentally go to shit they're like how
it's gonna blow up or something no
literally turn to shit we will all
become turds but at least carrot juice
will be happy again yeah weird thing
it's hard to get invested over a
character we barely see there's not
really much of an emotional connection
to justify the end of the world you know
don't listen to him carrot juice you've
got a ton of personality that we're
exploring well I'm talking the world
will be so happy to see you happy again
or we'll die trying as well as the world
yes I said we oh she's having cake with
a lion and a unicorn now
[Applause]
[Music]
what's that well yes I'd love to play
football with you oh except I don't have
my talks yeah I read your comments the
last time I did the sponsorship
you're right I should have done this
joke so I'm doing it now where can I get
a tux wear I don't look like a loser in
public who doesn't have a tux
that must be the black tux mailing me my
order that I never placed everyone wants
to look good for that special event but
they don't want to fork out a ton of
money for it either
well the black tux com is your answer
with high quality rental suits and
tuxedos delivered to your doorstep it's
such an easy way to rent suits and tuxes
online most suits go for something like
1,200 bucks but at the black tux they
start at $95 they let you create your
own look and choose from a ton of great
stylist their expert customer care has
your back every step of the way and it's
completely done online you can even do a
free home try on so you can see the fit
and feel the quality of your suit months
before your big event and after ordering
your suit they'll have it to you 14 days
before the event even starts and if
anything is less than perfect the black
tux will send you a free replacement
right away when your event is over you
just drop your rental back in the mail
and shipping is free both ways and hey
you want to get 20 bucks off your
purchase just visit the black tux comm
slash nostalgia critic that's right just
go to the black tux consolation
nostalgia Creek and you'll get $20 right
off your purchase all I got to do is put
this beautiful tuxedo on and I'll be
ready to play football there is no
footage of doubling football because doc
does not have a football football scheme
they remind him of his lack of nice
community however here's some footage of
him and that awesome tux with a drawing
of what he thinks a football looks like
visit the black tux comm premium rental
suits and tuxedos deliver
[Applause]
so Ellis travels to when the header and
his family made the crowns of the White
Queen and the Queen of Hearts only
princesses then it looks like the crown
doesn't fit the giant head though
causing the crowd to laugh you know for
being Hatter's they really suck at it
didn't they prepare for this know what I
was going to say my trademark thing it
was going to be a big deal and I'm not
sure why it being interrupted is still
trying to make it a big deal you are
unfit to rule a row Sabbath she loses
the crown and vows vengeance on the
headers wouldn't it make more sense to
Val vengeance on the lady that made fun
of her and the Hatter's father balls him
out
you will believe a character you don't
give a shit about is trying to make you
give a shit about him Alice tells the
Hatter about how his family's going to
get killed but he doesn't care so she
tries to tell the family but they're in
the middle of fighting off incredibly
good so she goes to try and stop the
Queen of Hearts from hitting her head
while time tries to follow her but comes
across the header during his tea party
again in all honesty this scene has a
real legit Alice in Wonderland feel it's
different levels of insanity trying to
relate to each other and getting nowhere
and it's actually clever as well as
entertaining if you fix me but even
that's botched in an attempt to throw a
kind of twist in there and the young
Alice joins you for tea it's always time
for you and your gun dance yeah so when
Alice showed up in the first film she
was actually freeing them that's why
they were at the table the whole time
why is that supposed to be fun wasn't it
crazier or even mad that they were just
sitting there the whole time because
they wanted to
nobody said all I really wanted so that
they're prisoners there they just wanted
them to be in their own little world
because it's enjoyable again you're
trying to add logic in something that
doesn't need it the series really is
like the villain from carebears in
Wonderland trying to add logic and order
to a world that shouldn't have any
except in that he's the bad guy here
it's just Disney and I still the better
adaptation by the way Alice travels to
the Hatter's childhood and if you think
him as an adult was boring an awkward
very nice
that's what my father says isn't this
just what you imagined with the Mad
Hatter as a little kid
imagine the animated one as a chow down
Singh off the walls or the Martin Short
one acting like a wild animal and this
one as bland as that cute who gets axed
off to prevent to the sit there too many
of them what are we going to do and this
pipe is not being directed by Tim Burton
it still somehow has the exact same
shitty backstory as as Willy Wonka
remake the function why can't my
limiting ideas get through to your
slightly less limiting ideas despite
having two attempts to tell the family
how to avoid getting murdered Alice once
again that collects too so she can stop
the Queen of Hearts from hitting her
head which it turns out is because her
sister stole a tart and blamed her did
you eat the tops next she'll be telling
me she ate Marceline's fries Alice try
stopping the accident but she only ends
up causing it starting her head turning
huge she realizes now that she can't
change time and it was wrong to meddle
with it but she also realizes that the
headers family is still alive go
meddling oh wait the answer time catches
up with Alice though and she observes
they slowly die and the end of the world
will take place if the chronosphere is
not returned
so naturally Alice looks into her heart
and tells him to piss off
she is literally looking at a dying man
and the end of the goddamn world is upon
us but she is so freakin crazy she
belongs in a mental institution well I'm
glad you agree with me movie but huh
okay so apparently she passed out when
she traveled through the looking-glass
and they took her to a mental ward
textbook case of female hysteria
untreatable some say okay what are they
gonna do with this
well she escapes three is a seat why
thanks me it was important to remind me
of that me and she goes back through the
looking-glass
that whole thing lasted three minutes
why the hell do we have that detour hi
critic I just wanted to give you some
incredibly important information that we
were delayed for just a moment but we're
back on track and he's still Sacko just
go
as a DEP couldn't get any whiter
apparently thinking his parents are dead
is killing him can't tell if he's dying
of a broken heart or a broken career
[Music]
never Alice again I'm putting you on a
watch list header suddenly gets better
hearing the news the his family is alive
and that the Queen of Hearts most likely
has them I'm going to that is such a
hatter thing to say god he's such a
well-defined character so they all try
breaking into the Queen's hideout I
don't really know what it is where they
find his family is in an ant farm hi dad
been waiting a long time for this but
they all get caught because even though
Alice verbally clarified the importance
of tying knots she forgot to verbally
clarify the importance of bringing
weapons to a battle kind of a dumbass
captain are you the Queen takes control
of time and his machine to travel back
with her sister no no all of it but the
guards decide they don't like the Queen
and let her heroes go why the hell did
you betray or when she was still there
as the Queen takes her sister to the
tart moment so she can finally confess
her lie
so the moral is everyone's a terrible
person it's the Seinfeld finale of
fantasies but the film follows Timecop
logic as the Queen sees herself which
somehow starts freezing over the entire
world so just a reminder you can't
change the past except the one you can
totally absolutely change the past don't
seem to recall her opening the door and
freezing the world the first time she
stole the tarts the Hatter was sad they
tried to get the chronosphere back where
it belongs as everyone starts crusting
over goodbye I have cherished every
moment with all of you gentlemen it has
been a privilege playing with you
tonight
allas of course gets it back in time as
the world is just barely saved and the
white queen finally confesses her fault
[Music]
that's just great
hey remember all those decapitated heads
in the first film it's okay because she
forgave her for the tart hey remember
that frog that was taken away from his
family and executed it's okay because
she forgave her for the tart remember
the mass genocide oppression and
countless lives destroyed because of
every single one of these dumbass idiots
dirt it was all down to tards I think
the real question is not who's the real
villain but who isn't the real villain
so yeah things are okay apart from the
countless graves as Alice goes home to
see her mother signing the deed to her
ship mr. Harcourt time is money
I'm afraid he most certainly is not
where did you come from I walked right
through the walls arrestor she escaped
from a mental institution by I may not
be able to change the past but I can
learn from it but we're not doing that
you want me to sign them it's just a
shit but there's always another you had
that whole scene in the movie we're just
going to ignore it you and my mother and
I only have one okay I guess
straitjacket so useless over the power
of learning lessons I knew that you
would headstrong all north
you're not a nice man Hamish oh that one
hurt so they don't sign over the ship
and Alice's mother instead decides to
give up her home to go sailing with her
daughter I'm in tide wait for no man
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so that was awful like really awful
like really awful like really awful
really awful but I have to admit I
didn't dislike it as much as the first
one the first one had virtually no
elements of Wonderland at all apart from
maybe a little bit of the look this one
at least hapten to some moments the
majority of times character was both
clever and charming scenes with the
chessboard and Tea Party felt more
whimsically surreal and fun like in the
original book and the overall visual
style is quite impressive even better
than the first aside from that though it
still doesn't get across what makes
Alice and wonderland a timeless story it
still adds too many rules too many
limitations and too many attempts to
make it a big thrilling adventure when a
small abstract story is more than enough
both of these Alice films are bad but I
can surprisingly stomach this one a
little more for the few good moments it
had on the whole though it's still an
oyster gone bad okay and I'm done I'm
gonna go home and watch the good Alice
in Wonderland movie oh you got happy you
ruined the lives of God knows how many
countries along the way but I'm happy
once more and what made you so ecstatic
well the fact that you're Alice in
Wonderland doesn't exist anymore me
talking about I got a copy of it right
here ah it shut that's right critic
that's all we've done to your Alice in
Wonderland we've turned it into shit now
are people
Wonderland they won't see the animated
one all I'll see a shit shit shit Alice
will you kindly pay attention and recite
your lesson Oh God
time-traveling and the Mad Hatter's a
dramatic character and the end of the
world because of a time Alice what in
the flaming ass are you talking about oh
I'm sorry but you see Tim Burton said
Tim Burton no one's going to remember
his later films half of them are flops
even the ones he produced oh then I
guess like me people are waking up and
seeing the stories that really lasts
whatever come now it's time for duck
dynasty but this world was called under
loud sounds stupid and it had a
breakdancing Mad Hatter talking like a
moral and there was a lot of discussion
about homes she shut up and I was in a
mental institution with that I'd believe
we could God knows how many people just
to make an awkward actor happy I swear
to Jesus eros I will strangle you with
my bullet if you don't stuff your god
damned yapping
[Music]
[Applause]
very nice head
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shot on this week we are doing Catholic
Relief Services they work with
organizations around the world to help
poor and vulnerable people overcome
emergencies earn a living for
agriculture and access affordable health
care they helped millions of farmers
worldwide recover from natural disasters
and civil strife and build resilient
farming systems their vision is to
promote solidarity and compassion
through timely emergency and recovery
actions that address the needs of the
most vulnerable as a leader in
international humanitarian aid they
often go where others don't
carrying out a wide array of
health-related activities tailored to
the needs of the countries and the
communities they serve if you look at
their site in their YouTube channel you
can see all the various people who
contribute to this cause as well as all
the folks in places they transform for
the better click on the link and play a
big part in their mission to help em
here
you